was ist relevant was ist eine nachricht
wert die schreckensherrschaft des die
flüchtlingskatastrophe im mittelmeer
oder in westafrika unsere zeit erscheint
vielen grausamer als jede zuvor
wo bleibt das positive nicht nur teile
des publikums fühlen sich gelähmt von
den nachrichten
auch journalisten sind der fokussierung
aufs negativer müde
selbst unter vielen reparaturen und
redaktoren wächst der frust
sie wollen die nachrichten nicht schauen
wenn sie den ferien sind und sie wollen
auch nicht dass ihre kinder nachrichten
schauen sie sagen es ist zu spät beim
dänischen fernsehen versucht die
nachrichtenredaktion seit ein paar
jahren etwas neues
lösungsorientierte nachrichten als
ergänzung zum kritischen journalismus so
hat nachrichtenchef ulrich hob den
zuschauerschwund gebremst konstruktive
nachrichten
das ist die idee dass unsere arbeit auf
eine neue weise bedeutungsvoll sein
können nicht nur schlechte nachrichten
sind nachrichten durch eine gute
geschichte können wir die leute
inspirieren
dänemarks reporter sollen journalisten
mit einer aktiveren rolle in der
gesellschaft seien nicht nur über
probleme berichten sondern teil der
lösung sein
jeden tag eine geschichte die zeigt was
besser gehen kann
ein paradebeispiel zu viele antibiotika
in der schweinezucht ein riesiges
problem in dänemark doch anstatt wie
üblich nach dem skandal und
entschuldigen zu suchen präsentierte die
dänische tagesschau vorbilder im ausland
in den niederlanden geht ein landwirt
einen neuen weg bekämpft erfolgreich
bakterien mit probiotika statt mit
antibiotika und wenige monate nach dem
beitrag folgten führende de rheinische
landwirte diesem beispiel
es ist so einfach aber für die meisten
leute ist es nicht so einfach umzudenken
wir wollen zurück zum kran des
journalismus und für mich geht es in den
nachrichten darum den leuten die beste
verfügbare version der wahrheit zu geben
und das werkzeug dazu ist die welt mit
beiden augen zu sehen
wir benennen die probleme wir liefern
aber auch eine perspektive
der konstruktive journalismus könnte zur
bewegung werden kann man die
flüchtlingskrise als chance sehen als
herausforderung an alle von uns die
wochenzeitung die zeit gibt sich seit
jahren in solchen ansätzen und ist mit
diesem kurs eines der ganz wenigen
printmedien die in der medienkrise leser
dazugewonnen haben auch der zürcher
tages anzeiger hat gute erfahrung
gemacht bei seinen sonderausgaben mit
lösungsorientierten journalismus nun
will die zeitung konstruktive
geschichten zur routine machen
einmal in der woche soll ein mitarbeiter
eine lösung für ein problem vorschlagen
dank aktion die negativ geschichte die
traurige die kritische die verzweifelte
bricht die amazone so wirklich zeigen
dass gibt es gibt grund zur hoffnung es
geht muss oder freie blick und das
grafisch wie nachhaltig und in
reaktionen gegenüber der nasa ausdruck
die tagesschau des schweizer fernsehens
auch hier kennt man die ideen der
dänischen kollegen unter konstruktiv
verstehen die journalisten hier
allerdings vor allem zusammenhänge zum
geschehen zu liefern hintergründe
aber sie sind auch offen für positives
zum beispiel hoffnungsvolle geschichten
vom kontinent afrika zu bringen etwa
über das dortige wirtschaftswachstum
zynische journalisten weisheit news are
good news und alles andere hat nicht
stark von der schule los ist so integer
teil positive geschichten in dem sind
genauso gut genauso spannend sie
allerdings dass sich
nachrichtenredaktionen bewusst am morgen
in der 70 frage stellen weil sich jetzt
konstruktiv jahr satz
und da muss ich sagen hat die weniger
doch genau das wollen die dänen das
konstruktive zum system erheben es geht
ihnen nicht um wohlfühl news sondern um
nachricht mit zukunftsperspektive und
eine erweiterte rolle von reportern
das wird für debatten sorgen hoffentlich
für konstruktive wie kann es ein
besseres morgen geben ich denke das ist
ein teil dessen was journalismus tun
kann
besonders des service bügel für mich ist
das verantwortungsvolle journalismus
dafür will ich mich selber ändern
ich will unsere art von nachrichten
ändern und die kultur die wir fliegen
und den austausch darüber unter
journalisten welt